[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome very good to be with
you and have your company now my first
guest in this brand new series is the
chinese dissident artist and now author
ai weiwei
starting off as a filmmaker in the late
70s he's now famed for his provocative
and political work perhaps best known
for his art installations from the 14
000 life jackets used by refugees he
attached to a berlin concert hall to
filling a gallery in london with a
hundred million handcrafted sunflower
seeds to question the made in china
phenomenon
he has also disowned one of his most
famous designs the bird's nest stadium
that was at the heart of the 2008
beijing olympics citing serious concerns
over the chinese government's human
rights record
following the destruction of his studio
and imprisonment in china he left his
home country but continues to document
create and agitate he joins me now from
his latest abode in portugal sadly
covert travel restrictions means we
cannot be together in person but ai
weiwei welcome
thank you
your latest creation is your book your
memoir a thousand years of joys and
sorrows
what have you learned about yourself
from writing it
well i
think the purpose to writing this book
is to find out my relations with my
father
and
i realized during the detention i
realized
you know most of our memories either
being erased or destroyed by the
authority
so i think the the most dangerous thing
the authority is doing
to
to authoritarian state is to
trying to change the facts what happened
in the past
so i have to establish a real
understanding of my father's condition
in almost past 100 years
and
to write down what i know and to leave
this to myself
yes that's the big driving force your
son who you say will be your ultimate
arbiter
i talked about you being imprisoned
being under arrest for charges of a tax
bill of millions this was after your
artistic activities and speaking out
against the chinese government online
but when you talk about your father he
was internally exiled you were with him
you were separate from your mother he
was exiled for being a poet and a
so-called intellectual and you lived in
a hole in the ground together and i
wonder
for you how much that prepared you for
your own imprisonment
well my father was exiled in xinjiang
province where the wiggly people today
have the re-education camps
so we are probably the first group moved
to there to be re-educated
and my father spent about 20 years in
that region and
forbidden to write
anything
so he's been doing hard labor and also
we've been punished to live underground
in a hall
so all those experience
i
later
much later
realized that made me become
me today
i
would look at a society or political
system with a different angle and a very
different perspective
and in terms of your situation now
you're talking to me from portugal are
you able to go back to china
i don't think
i can be safely stay in china maybe they
would allow me to
to get into china because i'm a chinese
citizen
but
i wouldn't know i would be safe in there
and also i would not know if they
would let me out
i talked to my mom
almost daily and the last sentence she
always tell me do not come back she
knows i may want to go back so your
mother's still there but you can't go
back
what do you think would happen to you
um
who knows it's never you never can
predict you know i know so many people
disappeared i know many people been
sentenced heavily for
didn't do anything wrong
you just don't know i mean i suppose
that's the thing when you i went to the
exhibition that you held at the royal
academy in london uh in which you
recreated some of those scenes of your
own imprisonment the 81 days people may
remember you also kind of crowdfunded to
pay the millions that you were said to
owe in tax some people were just
throwing the money in uh to your garden
i i understand with paper airplanes but
actually i i understand you formed a
bond with the guards they had to follow
you everywhere to go to the toilet to
the shower that came across in the art
that you created about it and those
guards started to ask you for advice is
that right about their own lives their
love lives
yes they also
um they are soldiers but they're only
very young you know 20 years old and
they know nothing about outside the
world the only thing they do is trying
to
protect someone like me they don't even
know the name
so they will have a lot of curiosity
about the outside about everything
in life i think they they also
just like me as a prisoners as
youngsters they they really like to know
more about sex or
or any experience like that you know
it's uh
i don't have a rich experience but i
still can tell them more
we've got that out at this point but i
was going to say of course some of your
formative years in that time
you went to new york and had your own
education i'm sure but i was going to
come to that
the guards that were tasked with making
sure you were where you were meant to be
you say they didn't know who you were do
people in china know who ai weiwei is
before 2008 i started to design this
stadium
and more people knows me because i was
architects
and later one i started to in
questioning the state's corruption and
all those kind of
mishandling of a school's
building and which cost
over 5000 students
lost their life
and
i've been totally shuttered off my
internet and also on the media so
i guess not not so many people know me
i think that's fascinating that you
could be so famous outside of your
country
and yet inside your country you've been
removed or erased or disappeared not not
physically of course but just from the
record because how much do you think
people
in china know that they don't know
things well
china under the
the world outside china is two different
world it's too parallel world they hold
very different understanding about
humanity about
freedom of speech about
political ideologies
so they openly
ignore or or criticize what is happening
in the west
so it's china have a 1.4 billion people
and they formally
believe in
communist
propaganda and that propaganda is very
successful
and also therefore very strong
censorship so they would make sure
boys like me who never been heard
and then i suppose that's you've got to
question how successful your activism is
then
you know if it's for the rest of the
world not for the chinese
well they see the potential danger of my
activism
online because at that time for a moment
i was quite uh
quite vivid you know i raised a
strong
voice
but that's why they have to
put this kind of punishment on me but i
wonder you say in your book
young people in china today have no
knowledge at all of the student protests
in gentleman square in 1989 and if they
knew they might not even care for they
learn submission before they develop an
ability to raise doubts and challenge
assumptions
i think so you know they're kind of like
a bird has been encouraged for too long
they cannot challenge to
to fly
what will china listen to
do you think a cultural boycott would
work for instance
i don't think so i don't think anything
in the west
doing this kind of boycott would work
because they simply china can
suffer
you know the the government is not going
to suffer but the people really
understand what
is
like when they don't have that much
so
in that kind of competition china can go
very low and i don't think the west can
compete with china i was thinking about
the cultural boycott because of course
you know museums and galleries still
collaborate heavily in china and yet
actually in the sports world we've seen
anti-china messages on certain sports
people's shoes serena williams has come
out for instance recently for feng shui
the chinese tennis superstar who made
allegations online that she was sexually
assaulted by a chinese official uh those
allegations very quickly deleted we
should say she was also having an affair
with that individual
i i just wonder do you think any of
those actions
are are with merit
i think those actions are really helping
the western public to understand china
but for chinese
they know this is not gonna work because
the big corporations in the west they're
eager to make a bigger profit in china
nobody in the west corp in the
cooperative world will bore cut china so
just a few sport men or artists
certainly will not work
i mentioned the tennis player feng shui
talking about what happened to her
how brave do you have to be to do what
she did what she did is nothing to do
with the brave
you know i think it's also miss
interpretation
she is a sport person which is like a
soldier in the army
is raised by a chinese state any person
in sport
being considered as a property of the
party
so what she did i don't think it's
that brave she feels she has been
mistreated and she posts on her own
personal
blog
or being deleted then later she performs
according to the you know the state's
will you know to let her perform she's
fine
and what
is more disgusting is
the
the
tennis association
and the olympics
jewelry or olympics committee trying to
cover up
they are they're not really
make a
demanding to have the true thought
i mean you may not agree that it's brave
you see you explain the reason why you
think she did it i suppose it's just you
talked about what can happen to you in
china and there is concern about what
will happen to her now
oh yes she's seen a horrible situation
because she made this uh
you know i don't know uh
you know she is she is regret or not
but she seems now only performs on the
same line as the state
and of course being forced
so it's business that's the only hope
business is dominating in every corner
of the world
why do you think even cultural boycotts
haven't caught on in the west of china
we see them of israel for instance but
we don't see the same levels of outrage
a lot of the time over the imprisonment
of uyghur muslims for instance who you
mentioned earlier well
i don't know
have you seen any successful of a
cultural board called which kind of
shaking uh
uh society like china you know it's not
possible
and uh
with many many uh regions
for sports culture boycott just simply
doesn't work
china has been isolated and locked up
for
years before
and
they survived
are you resigned to china staying like
this then or are you still do you still
have fight in you wait
i do fight all the time because the
fight is nature of my life it's not
because i want to win it's only because
i have to fight that's
that's i have no other choice
who are you fighting for now if we've
established that those in china don't
know you and can't see you
and it's now you have to live away from
your mom and you have to live in
portugal how effective can you be do you
think i'm fighting for a lot of people
who who is
in same condition as me we have been
forced out from our land in a way when
we cannot have a normal communication
with our family
and uh you know because of all kind of
reasons so we have to find a way to
express ourself and to let her voice to
be heard
it was just i was thinking of the
russian putin critic alexei navalny who
went back
in russia now in jail do you ever feel
have you ever thought about going back
because you can make that kind of impact
my life is not just making
impact my life is about
how to successfully express myself
so
i could go back you know it's not i'm
scared or afraid of anything but i also
have a responsibility i do have family
and also have to care about what my mom
think about
do you think you'll ever see your mum
again
i see her online but
i
of course i always want to go back so
how do you live with that on a personal
level that must be very difficult
not very difficult it's just the idea
of i cannot go back it's difficult to
accept
but the other sense is pretty normal
many people has been separated from
their parents if you look at the
refugees you know in the world
and there's millions of millions of
people they can and
they are separated you talked about your
your role being to be able to express
yourself your art is political
sometimes deliberately
vulgar some would say or offensive do
you think you've ever taken it too far
no far from being too far i've been too
soft and my voice is very low
and
yeah
in what way why have you been too soft
because the world is just being
indifferent if we say the whole world
basically is a hypocrisy you know people
don't care they pretend they care but
they don't care at all
and
you know my voice is doesn't matter
i was thinking then about the fact that
you brought up refugees and when you
recreated the image that had gone around
the world of a three-year-old syrian
refugee boy alan kurdi who'd washed up
dead on a greek beach was incredibly
upsetting image you then posed yourself
as him and some people did feel that was
utterly tasteless even if you were
raising the plight of refugees
i think i post this image purposely to
make those people think that tasteless
makes them feel bad because those people
are really hypocritic
crowd they don't know how many children
has been drawn in that
sea in the ocean his brother just
a few meters away from him people
doesn't even care you know the whole
world is just so much uh
so fake and so pretending and the
refugee situations and then become even
worse nobody even asks the questions
anymore so you did that because you
wanted to point out people's hypocrisy
to them but people may that photo did
have a real image people felt it was
enough as it was it didn't need you to
pose what did you actually care what did
you create by doing that
i don't care what those people think
about i don't care about you know
whatever they think about
and i think
i don't even know they're there i don't
know if they are human at all
if they understand what happens to this
world what happens to those refugees
the only thing you left is angry
you know you see the world pretending
nothing's happening but
that would leading to even bigger
disaster
so that sort of criticism doesn't even
enter your mind it doesn't bother you no
that makes me joy
happy you know i feel attached to those
very fake people and they are shaking
somehow
so cancel culture this idea this new
form of western censorship you talk
about politically correct extremism
none of this sort of gets to you
i think it's horrible uh besides china
you know you can see what happens in the
west basically it's totally fake and the
hypocrisy dominates the world under the
culture
in what way
you can see
they are so unrealistic when they
start discussion uh about the world
politics
you see
this turkish journalist being killed
in
you know the journalists being killed in
turkish embassy actually he's a
saudi or american
journalist but
americans still doing business with
turkey or with
saudi and trunks said clearly they will
not stop
to do the business with saudi
is that
clear enough the whole western world the
whole western world start selling
because they want business
is that enough to see what is the real
human rights record and the hypocrisy
that you're talking about so i'm
interested to go back to no no no
there's millions of these kind of
stories you for us british pulled out
junior sanchi from the embassy now he
still ended up in the british prison
is that
julian provide the you know the
so-called
wikileaks
which exposed the criminal act
by governments
and that is a foundation of
investigate journalism
sorry but he also didn't go back to a
country where there were allegations of
sexual assault those allegations of that
that's could you let me finish it
i have listened to you that
you make a very long acquisition the
sweden already was charged
they already withdraw the charge why you
repeat to say that that is no no they
didn't withdraw the charge the charge
expired there is a huge difference and
i'm a keen keen you will appreciate as a
journalist and as someone who doesn't
like the world
why don't you let him go back to sweden
then he has to go back to us let him go
back to sweden to facing the charge
sorry you say that i made an error i did
not for the record i think your main
error had expired
the facts are the facts why why
no i don't think that's a fact using a
fact which is not working
i'm using a fact that isn't working okay
what would you create if you could
you said that you haven't done all that
you wanted your voice has been too low
what is the piece of art or the
political act or the installation that
you would create that you perhaps
haven't done oh there's too many i have
done very little i should be humbly
saying i haven't started yet
i was interested that you said before
that art is a sign of social health
and i wonder what you think of the way
that it's now being traded as an asset i
don't know i cannot really describe
the other people's behavior well i think
i was also thinking of
nfts non-fungible tokens these unique
digital assets a new big thing in art i
wonder what you make of them
i don't think that's new big thing in
the art i mean that's new bigs in in
financial world or in technical world i
have no idea but nothing big in art
as part of the market i suppose do you
think that they're a fad or do you think
they're brilliant do you own any no no i
i
i'm not interested in it but i may
if
i find the right
topic or right moment to carry right
message why not but i still cannot
associate it with it
the last time we met in person i
actually wanted a photo of us
and you were very funny because you
insisted on taking it on my phone as a
selfie so i could have an ai way way yes
you would have an origin on work
so who owns that me or you
of course uh it's down by me your own
set because your property
okay i just wanted to clarify that it
was a very good picture but you also
said to me that you were done with art
you were getting frustrated and perhaps
you would be happy just doing something
simple you said to me you'd be happy
sitting on a bench
yeah today in the interview they said i
cannot sit in a chair they wanted you
know the background to be more clean so
i'm sitting on a stool
you are sitting on a comfortable chair
do you know what though i'd much rather
we were together sitting outside it
would be lovely that would be nice
thank you very much for talking to me
again
thank you
thank you so much for being with us
until we meet again mask up stay safe
and goodbye
[Music]
you